we have big breaking news is a big story
from this weekend and a 70 year old man
named Dave 's 82 women in the world
poker tour ladies event so in in
Southern Florida the World Poker Tour is
currently on and uh this fella right
here Dave she's aspirational uh the
ladies no limit hold of event Seminole
guarded 83 entries of the prize pool of
17 430 here's here's the this guy's
having a good time
not Sports yeah it's not like a physical
activity there it is mop the floor but
but it's but this is true of any but
look men are better than women at chess
yeah men are better than women at poker
poker is actually more obvious than
chess chess I don't have an explanation
for maybe it's it's related to
aggression and risk taking the reason
why men are tend to win uh beat women in
poker is and not completely there are
some women who are good like in any
other sport it's because men are more
aggressive and are more take bigger
risks they will play aggressively they
will they will make bigger bets they
will take bigger risks and they will get
paid out for it women are less likely to
so of course this guy won he won first
place he gets 5 555 and what's what they
said is uh ebony Kenny another uh female
I believe she's a pro poker player said
maybe Dave was overheard saying quote he
could pretend to identify as a woman
because they allow anything nowadays and
by maybe I mean 100 now as we were we as
we were launching the show I got word
that Dave actually gave a statement to
timcast.com thanks Dave and my
understanding is that he was literally
protesting that they allow males to
compete against females so I have not
actually seen his statement until now
we're gonna read it on the show Dave
Hughes responds to winning women's poker
event
Hughes said he drove over five hours
from Orlando to visit a friend competing
in the seven million dollar main event
at the Seminole Hard Rock in Florida
upon arriving in the poker tournament he
was one of the play a hand of Poker but
learned the only event available was
particip for participation was the
ladies gnome and hold them quote I
figured why not the ladies as you know
are just as Fierce capable as
competitive as the men in poker and
smell a lot better as well for the
record I'm 100 against men taking
advantage of women in sports where
strength and muscle muscle make it quite
unfair as we can all clearly see with
men breaking all records set by women in
every sport across the board while
pretending to be women it's pathetic and
embarrassing that we allow our women to
be abused and victimized by this
nonsense and eventually the count the
country will wake up to this and put a
stop to it our young girls and women who
dedicate their lives to playing sports
deserve better better than that and the
silent majority are starting to speak up
damn well it's you know the worst part
of the whole story is a trailblazer the
prize was originally 4 125 but because
he's a man that gave him 5 500. really
messed up so apparently in uh the World
Series I think it's the World Series of
Poker I think we may we may have written
this up
um I'm not sure if we did they have a
ladies event as well and it's illegal to
Bar men from entering a tournament so in
Florida what they said was they were
like we legally cannot say someone is
based on their sex not allowed to enter
an event so he's allowed to play they
are just like we hoped people would
honor it in I think it's the World
Series of Poker in Vegas what they do is
it's a ten thousand dollar fee to enter
with 90 off if you're female
that's still illegal they're they're
saying aha we found a loophole to
discriminate discriminate against
someone based on sex does not work that
way anybody who wanted to sue could at
the federal level and they would win you
can't do that there's a dude who's
famous for going around to bars that had
ladies night and 5 filing lawsuits and
winning instantly summary judgment you
cannot offer cheaper drinks to women
based on the fact that they are women
you can't you can't do it and so this
guy would just be like you can't do it
I'm suing I win a couple Grand but but
good on this guy for speaking out that
guy ruined ladies nights at every bar
now the women aren't showing up for
cheaper drinks they were putting
bounties on them so other players about
to use a financial incentive to knock a
player out of the game so if you were to
beat him and take all his chips you
would get paid extra by someone else
didn't work he won he he actually won
now do you think let me ask you this
random guy who wasn't planning on
entering the tournament who just drove
up there on a whim to watch his friend
play
he still beat all the men who actually
shut up to compete in this tournament
I don't think it's that surprising yeah
you know honestly I mean men take men
take bigger risks that's part of the
that seems like part of the the fun of
testosterone it's science it's like
there's a little bit of fearlessness
there small brain I don't think it's I
wouldn't say a small brain but uh well
you could and it'd be fun to say well
there's there's a there's like a whole
IQ thing where more women are in the in
the middle than in the right the greater
male variance hypothesis I think it's
probably the aggressive the
aggressiveness is is you know the
risk-taking and stuff whereas men are
more uh more prone to take risk well
every time I have a friend that I've
gone to casinos with and every time
we've gone together like he takes big
risks and I take like no risks and he
makes a lot of money and I end up losing
80 or whatever and he's like oh you need
to take risks you know and I'm like oh
but it's my money
it's just longer so this I suck at it
this is uh this guy Dave said some risks
but he said quote I'd ever do it again
but it sure caused a fuss and created a
buzz and a lot of extra prize money for
the ladies women are every bit as good
as men in any game that requires mental
skill and wits he is technically
technically correct and it's the greater
male variance hypothesis what do you
what what he's saying is if you were to
probably do if you probably were to
average it out you would find that the
average man and average woman are
probably comparable in general skill in
games like poker or chess the issue is
they are substantially more stupid men
who suck and competent men who are who
are who are good because there's greater
male variants so most women fall in the
middle and then I feel bad for women
because that means it means for for
women they are more likely to encounter
stupid men and smarter men yeah so it's
just frustrating across the board and
this is every time dealing with men as a
woman that's right well I'm sure you're
a pain in the ass look because most of
them are dumber than you yeah and then a
lot of them are smarter but they're a
couple a couple well it's actually a a
bell curve so you have I was talking
about me personally oh yeah for sure but
I mean like the the day-to-day
interaction for a woman working in an
office is probably going to be with the
lower end of the bell curve of men and
so women are probably experiencing many
more stupid men than men experience of
women yep well you know you talk to
these male feminists and you try to
explain this principle of them you say
men are more likely to be smart or dumb
whereas women are more likely to be
average and they go I've never noticed
that women seem less intelligent than me
I have bad news buddy the bad news about
where you are on that Spectrum right now
whenever dude
you're so much smarter than us I'm like
ooh it makes sense I already said male
feminists you know it's at that lower
end of development but I mean it makes
sense that you know dudes that are more
aggressive and actually that are smart
guys they're going to be the ones that
are going to go out and try to start
something on their own and I'm I'm sure
yeah absolutely yes but in an office
it's going to end up with the midwits
yes being in office is awful yeah so a
lot of these prominent feminist writers
are midwits and uh so for Frozen like
you like the women who work at Jezebel
and vice Oh you mean like Taylor Lorenz
and all of these they're Midwest medium
matters they are slightly above average
in intelligence and that means they're
going to be surrounded by a bunch of
really dumb men and then they're gonna
you know the perfect social support that
experience
yeah you got to understand this too the
the
I'm gonna swear but this is an actual
scientific term so I'm I'm warning
everybody this is the actual academic
phrase sneaky really that is not
an insult that is not a gag it's not a
joke it's a reference a little insulting
well it's a it's a reference to in
biology
in species you have the dominant men and
you have the dominant males and the
sneaky males and the sneaky
males will go in the middle of
the night in some species and then
reproduce under you know they'll sneak
in to reproduce while the dominant
strong man who is the authority is
unaware that's why they're called sneaky
male feminists are described
similarly in that they are men who will
say whatever they think no one wants to
hear in order to get access to
reproduction then you have the confident
you know I guess you know strong man
types who win or or through confidence
and Status are attractive to women so
you have the sneaky and then you
have the the sneaky though like
they're they're very like you can see
that when you look at them not when
you're in birth control not not when
you're a male feminist no not not when
you're a feminist and you're surrounded
by nothing but nothing and surprise
surprise it is no surprise to me that
these feminists are writing articles
being like all men are this way it's
like because you've surrounded yourself
with nothing but low quality sneaky
men well and they always project
that's why those guys always go men just
want to use women's bodies
you're telling me about yourself
I'm pretty sure Michael Knowles who
married his high school sweetheart and
had a family was intending on more than
just having a body of this person for
decades exactly and you and I were
speaking about this on my podcast a
while ago Libby but what they project in
such egregious ways they say
conservatives just want to use women for
their bodies and only see them as
birthing people even though they use
phrases like birthing person and now
they're all they're advocating for
surrogacy where you literally just use a
woman for her body and see her as a baby
maker rather than a person you're
committed to yeah I think everyone knows
how I feel about seriously we've been
through that indeed
yeah it's it's a self it's it's a
I don't know how you correct for this
problem when liberal women surround
themselves with male feminists you
repeal the 19th well I mean I don't
think that changes that women are going
to be surrounded by men who are going to
say whatever the women want to hear in
order to get access to banging them I
think there's a misconception right
about relationships I I think when you
fall in love with your high school
sweetheart you should probably marry
them
you should probably marry the person you
fall in love with and no wait that's not
what they're saying nowadays no nowadays
all these other things I saw this thing
on Instagram and it was like you're
gonna have three great loves in your
life and it went to list them and it was
like the first love right it's a
horoscope right no this was like it was
on Instagram I don't know it was the it
was the sneaky algorithm is what
it was okay like is this Instagram thing
he's like hey I'm number three right you
know it's the best one but it was like
it went through them all like all these
different things and it was like well
why not just why not just get together
with the person what's in love with
first what's happening is that's not a
feminist yeah are working for these
corporations like Vice BuzzFeed Etc and
they're surrounded by sneaky men
yes and again I'm not saying I love your
loophole it's not a loophole it's an
actual biological term like biologist
biologists describe this method of
reproduction as sneaky well I
appreciate it so what happens then when
these women are sitting around and
they're like what do you think about
sexual liberation of course the sneaky
are like yeah it's empowering
you should totally and Bang everybody
protest topless that'll show us in the
early days of the feminist movement the
feminists were not all gung-ho about
abortion it was men who got involved and
were like let's put abortion in and
everyone's like I get consequence free
sexual accidents I wanted to hook up I
don't want to have a family right so why
didn't you go it's like a Dennis in um
uh uh it's always sunny it's always
sunny when he you know he supports the
pro-choice because he's like I don't
have a family are you crazy
yeah that's bold of that show to do that
joke thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time